would you rather go on a cruise or a
road trip road trip comedy or thriller
comedy coffee or tea tea but only
slightly preferably neither how do you
get energized the
sun cats or dogs cats but I like dogs
too it's like a this or that is a little
bit tough with you you like everything
shower or bath oh shower for sure okay I
don't have the patience to take bath are
you a morning person or a night owl
Night Owl for sure would you rather get
on a phone call or text message text
probably I feel like the answer for you
is neither feel like it's just usually
yes just go sunrise or sunset sunrise
winter or summer summer sauna or ice
bath both okay that that's what you do
in in Norway that you go in the SAA and
then you take an ice bath and then you
go back in the SAA and you do that a few
times it's really nice